are you following all the same writing
advice but your dialogue still sounds
stiff dialogue is the best way to engage
your readers but it's also the hardest
thing to get right as an English
Professor I've seen even the best
students in my creative non-fiction
Workshop struggle with dialogue that is
until they learn a few simple tricks so
in this video I'm going to show you the
easiest way to write dialogue that's
engaging in authentic dialogue that
brings your characters to life and your
readers right there in the room with
them using examples from fiction
non-fiction and screenwriting along the
way plus I'm going to show you the
silent dialogue hack that turned There
Will Be Blood into a cinematic
Masterpiece by the end of this video not
only will you know what makes these
iconic examples of dialogue so engaging
but you'll also know how to write it
yourself and if you like learning about
the Art and Science of expert writing
then you are going to love my free
newsletter writer science link is down
below the like button last week as I Was
preparing for this video I went back and
rewatched There Will Be Blood because
it's just a shining example of some of
the best dialogue in cinema and even
though I've probably watched that movie
10 to 15 times this time I noticed
something particular that completely
changed how I see the film and we're
going to get to that but for now let me
just ask you this the title of the film
There Will Be Blood why do you think it
has that title keep that in mind because
when you understand this about D
dialogue the title and so much more
about that movie is going to suddenly
make a lot more sense speaking of films
have you ever watched a movie with
somebody who keeps pausing it to explain
what's happening hey man watch this part
this part is really good those guys are
the worst it totally ruins the
experience right unfortunately this is
exactly what so many writers do to their
readers and the worst part is they don't
even realize it take Stephen King for
example now nobody's going to say that
Stephen King is not a great writer he's
a master Storyteller but when it comes
to dialogue well it's not exactly his
strong suit when I read dialogue in
Stephen King I'm reminded of that famous
scene from Woody Allen's Annie Hall
where subtitles appear beneath the
conversation to explicitly spell out the
character's inner thoughts yeah yeah I
sort of dabble around you
know they're they're wonderful you know
they have a they have a quality well I I
I would like to take a serious
photography course and photography is
interesting because you know it's a it's
a new art form and a a set of aesthetic
criteria have not emerged yet aesthetic
criteria you mean whether it's a good
photo or
not the the medium enters in as a
condition of the art form itself now
you'll see the same kind of commentary
in a scene from Stephen King's novel
Carrie in which Sue and Tommy who are a
young couple they've just finished
making love in Tommy's Car Sue thought
herself suddenly loathsome she found she
could not bear that and so she Twisted
it at him when did you start making all
these big moral decisions after you
started [__] me she saw the Good
Humor fade from his face and was sorry
guess I should have just kept quiet he
said and pulled up his pants it's not
you it's me she put a hand on his arm
I'm ashamed see I know he said but I
shouldn't be giving advice I'm not very
good at it Tommy do you ever hate being
so well popular me the question wrote
surprise on his face contrast that with
these few lines of dialogue from Cormac
macarthy's All the Pretty Horses which
won the national book award in this
scene the protagonist John Grady Cole
meets with his father in a cafe the
father and the son are somewhat
estranged and John gravy has just
learned that his father sold a deed to
the family ranch so it's a little bit
awkward his father smoked he watched him
you still seeing that Barnett girl he
shook his head she quit you or did you
quit her I don't know that means she
quit you yeah his father nodded he
smoked two Horsemen passed outside the
road and they studied them and the
animals they rode his father stirred his
coffee a long time there was nothing to
stir because he drank it black he took
the spoon and laid it smoking on the
paper napkin and raised the cup and
looked at it and drank it he was still
looking out the window although there
was nothing there to see your mother and
me never agreed on a whole lot she liked
horses I thought that was enough that's
how dumb I was did you Spot the
Difference look in the text McCarthy is
nowhere to be found the author doesn't
intrude on the scene to interrupt the
dialogue or spell out the emotional
subtext he trusts his readers to connect
the dots and that's what makes the
dialogue so engaging now I want to
double click on that word engaging
because it's kind of cliche but I really
mean it in its truest sense pure
dialogue engages the reader it invites
them to participate in the meaning
making and that kind of dialogue feels
more genuine it's closer to the real
thing because in real life we honestly
have no idea what's going on inside the
mind of others
so why should an author presume to know
a character's intentions and private
thoughts and more importantly why should
their narrative put us in that position
of knowing this kind of authorial
assistance is called author splaining
when the author buts into a scene to
clarify every emotion or thought behind
his character's words and it's one of
the cardinal sins of dialogue so how can
you avoid the Trap of author splaining
well as with mansplaining the way to
avoid author's planning is to assume
that the other person might have ideas
of their own there are some language
forms that are a clear tell adverbs that
modify verbs of speech essentially any
word that ends with ly which comes after
words like said are a dead giveaway that
the author is trying to explain the
meaning of dialogue delete them really
go ahead delete them I know I know you
wrote These adverbs because you're
trying to be helpful but they're just a
crutch for bad writing instead put
yourself in that emotional mindset and
think of word choices and body language
that seem to flow naturally from that
emotion similarly phrases that
explicitly refer to emotional states are
doing the same work they're adding a
layer of commentary on what can
otherwise be shown through actions and
dialogue The Words a character chooses
or doesn't choose and the way those
language choices play against the
context tell us an awful lot about their
intentions and emotional state so trust
your readers to interpret the dialogue
when you step back you invite your
readers forward and this creates a more
immersive and yes engaging reading
experience have you ever had that kind
of immersive engaging reading experience
where the dialogue stays with you long
after you close the book I'm talking
about those really significant lines on
which which your entire interpretation
of the story hinges those lines of
dialogue that you want to talk to your
friends about afterwards well when
you're reading dialogue something to
consider is what's the purpose of
dialogue like in the story why at this
moment are we the author deciding to
break off from the narrative and go into
dialogue these are two different modes
of Storytelling and they serve different
purposes flat dialogue is more or less
the same as narrative it's just a
straightforward description of speech
events but dialogue that carries
multiple meanings invites readers to
actively engage in the story and it gets
them emotionally and intellectually
invested in your story let me give you a
simple example an exchange between a
husband and wife so the husband says I
think I'll go over to the pub now for a
drink will you
belong why don't you come too I don't
think I will not tonight I'm not sure I
may well which is it I don't need to say
now do I if I feel like it I'll come
over later notice how each line of this
dialogue subtly shifts the meaning of
the passage as a whole her first
response will he be long opens itself to
a few interpretations like is she
planning to do something while he's away
hoping that he'll be gone for long
enough is she tired of him and she wants
some time to herself is she feeling
needy worried that he'll be gone too
long now notice he answers her question
with another question why don't you come
too now is he sincere does he want her
to come she answers his invitation with
hesitation uncertainty why is she
hesitating what is she turning over in
her mind in her decision about whether
to join her husband at the pub what is
she weighing in the balance and when he
presses her well which is it the Line
opens up to multiple interpretations is
he irritated or is he feeling resigned
does he genuinely want her to join him
or is he secretly hoping that she'll
decline this ambiguity is a powerful
writing tool by leaving room for
interpretation you invite readers to
become co-creators in your story they'll
fill in the emotional gaps deciding for
thems what's really happening beneath
the surface and this active
participation creates a stronger bond
between your readers and your story it
gives them something to ponder discuss
and debate long after they' put down
your book so how do you actually write
dialogue with multiple meanings well
whenever you're writing dialogue it's
important to remember that you must
resist the urge to spell out every
emotion or intention explicitly instead
leave intentional gaps or even subtle
contradictions also watch out for long
passages that might be be revealing too
much and consider whether certain lines
might be viewed differently by different
readers now of course you don't want
your dialogue to be totally vague and
vapid but challenge yourself to write
lines that could mean different things
to different readers when readers are
invited to come up with their own
interpretations they become sewed up
into your story that interpretation is
an extension of themselves it draws them
in and keeps them invested in your story
but now let's flip the script instead of
looking at what's said let's think about
when things are not said because
sometimes the most powerful moments in
storytelling happen when nothing is said
at all and this is the key that unlocked
my Epiphany about There Will Be Blood
now think about it this way how can you
highlight a character's embarrassment or
shame without explicitly describing it
the thing that's so cringey about that
Stephen King dialogue is that rather
than conveying those feelings with
subtle dialogue he hits you over the
head with explicit descriptions of their
inner states and when the author inserts
themselves to describe emotions all
you're left with is some flat
one-dimensional dialogue but when you're
writing about embarrassment what's the
alternative after all in Waking Life
when we feel embarrassment or shame we
don't generally say it outright we
usually try to hide what we're
embarrassed of here's a more subtle
approach that you can use to convey
these deeper emotions take this scene
from a house for Mr biswas from vs
nightpool people have been roasting me
in the comments lately for my
pronunciation and again this is just
something that happens when you read
these words and you never heard them
said so I'm taking a Saab here but I'm
calling him Mr biswas so in this scene
it's Christmas Eve and Mr biswas decides
on a whim to buy a doll's house for his
daughter he can't afford it it's going
to cost him a month's wages so it's
really a scene of aspiration longing and
humiliation he got off his bicycle and
leaned it against the curb before he had
taken off his bicycle Clips he was
accosted by a heavy lited shopman who
repeatedly sucked his teeth the shopman
offered Mr biswas a cigarette and lit it
for him words were exchanged then with
the shop man's arm around his shoulders
Mr biswas disappeared into the shop not
many minutes later Mr B
and the shopman reappeared they were
both smoking and excited a boy came out
of the shop partly hidden by the large
doll's house he was carrying the doll's
house was placed on the handlebar of Mr
bis's cycle and with Mr biswas on one
side and the boy on the other wheeled
down the High Street notice What's
Happening Here there isn't a single line
of dialogue the entire exchange is
reported to us as though the author set
up a camera outside the shop window we
know Mr biswas and we know he can't
afford the doll's house but we don't
know what's being said inside and
certainly we want to know but that
dialogue is left out the reader is left
outside to infer what's being said from
the action as though we were watching a
silent film and in an even stronger move
the author deliberately in voids showing
us the embarrassing transaction itself
instead we are told words were exchanged
the passive language is perfect here it
emphasizes his lack of control as he's
maneuvered through this scene Mr biswas
is accosted the doll's house was placed
on the handlebars of his bike and Mr
biswas is wheeled down the street it's
funny but it's also quite painful
because the real action the moment that
the money changes hands is too
humiliating to depict this narrative
shows tremendous sympathy for Mr biswas
seeming to look away from a scene that's
just too embarrassing to report
directly by intentionally omitting the
dialogue and focusing on passive actions
the story shows us Mr bis's shame
without directly stating it and that
silence the absence of dialogue is
precisely what makes the scene so
powerful it works perfectly in this
scene but the question is how can you
use it in your own writing well the next
time you're writing a scene where a
character experiences deep embarrassment
or vulnerability experiment with silence
unlike Stephen King who needs to spell
out every painful detail try stepping
back and describing the scene indirectly
let your readers feel the weight of
what's not being said you have to listen
to the notes she's not
playing I can do that at home often the
strongest emotional impact comes from
what's left unspoken which brings me
back to There Will Be Blood now if
you've come this far into a video about
dialogue then I think it's safe to
assume that you've already seen the film
it's a masterpiece but just in case let
me set up this scene which occurs about
2third of the way through the film so
the movie is about Daniel Plan view a
hardcore Oil Man in the early 1900s
who's played by Daniel D Lewis he's all
about money and power no matter who gets
in his way but now standing in his way
is Eli Sunday this young preacher who's
running the Church of the third
Revelation in a Dusty little town where
Daniel is trying to drill for oil
they've been butting heads for a while
Daniel has already embarrassed Eli once
by shutting him out of a blessing of an
oil rig and when Eli tried to confront
Daniel in front of the men on his job
site well that did not go very well for
him
I'm going to bury you underr
I oh oh I'm going to bury you
underground but now Daniel Plan view
needs something from Eli a piece of land
from one of the members of his church
where he'd like to build a pipeline and
Eli's like oh you want the land well you
better get baptized first so now it's
Daniel walking onto Eli's turf he's
actually just killed someone the night
before and he's never stepped foot in a
church before so you could say he's
feeling a little out of place Eli calls
Daniel up to the pulpit and he's just
loving every second of this he starts
grilling Daniel making him confess all
of his sins in front of everybody
including one that really cuts to the
Bone I'm a sinner louder Daniel I am a
sinner I am a sinner I am sorry Lord I
am sorry Lord I want the blood I want
the blood you have abandoned your
child I've abandoned my child I will
never backslide I will never backslide I
was lost but now I am found I was lost
but now I'm found I have a Bandon my
child say it say it I abandoned my child
say it louder say it louder I've
abandoned my
child I've abandoned my my child I've
abandoned my boy but this is where
things get interesting because after the
baptism the camera starts pulling away
and then you notice that Daniel
approaches Eli to shake his hand and he
says something to him we don't know what
that totally wipes the grin off of Eli's
face of the the Lord
what did he say that's the
million-dollar question and it's one
that's open to interpretation it's a
question that the writer and director
Paul Thomas Anderson wants us to ask
it's the only time this kind of muted
dialogue happens in the film and in fact
it's the only time I can think of that
it's happened in any of his films and it
provokes such a strong reaction in Eli
you know that it's something bad but
like the scene that we just read with Mr
biswas we're left outside of that
dialogue and we kind of have to piece it
together but as I watched the film this
time around I think I figured it out so
as the camera is pulling back the song
that the congregation is singing is
there is power power power in the blood
there's it's a reference to the blood of
Christ but as Daniel approaches Eli what
I think he must say the thing that makes
the title make so much sense is oh There
Will Be Blood the technical name for
this style of dialogue is Ellipsis when
you strategically leave something out
and it's a great tool for engaging your
readers but it's only one writing tool
and it'll take more than ellipses if you
want to write masterful dialogue so for
31 other writing tools you need to check
out this video next because it's going
to show you a list of the best writing
tools that I've ever come across in
fiction non-fiction Cinema and even
Monty Python so be sure to go check it
out
[Music]